pelé bien le 28 juin ce sont les
élections municipales le second tour en
tout cas dans les communes où le maire
n'a pas été élus au premier à paris
c'est anne hidalgo qui est la favorite
des sondages la maire sortante
socialiste et lé droit dans ses bottes
dans sa politique anti voiture on a
appris hier de nouvelles initiatives
dans le programme dany d'algos en
matière de circulation automobile la
réduction à 30 km/heure de la vitesse
maximale à l'intérieur de paris sauf
dans quelques axes comme les champs
elysées la limitation à 50 km/heure de
la circulation sur le périphérique avec
une voix en moins pour les automobiles
et puis à terme
khalid al gore rêve de faire passer les
piétons sur le périphérique est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on y mettra des feux
rouges
on ne le sait pas encore mais en tout
cas la ligne est claire c'est
non aux voitures ferghana ziari est ce
que vous vous réjouissez de cette
politique anti voiture à paris et je
trouve que c'est quand même un assez
triste symbole pour une raison assez
simple savait que pendant très longtemps
la métropolisation l'urbanisation la
mobilité urbaine était considéré comme
un formidable vecteur d'ascension
sociale
mais ce soir elle a rappelé tout à
l'heure l'histoire de la prospérité
humaine est liée aussi à des
inaugurations et c'est vrai pour les
mobilités entre les villes entre les
villages
l'exode rural tel qu'on l'a connu au 19e
siècle l'accès aux métropoles l'accès
aux grands bassins d'emploi c'est
c'était une condition sinequanone de
l'augmentation de la prospérité des
populations manière générale et voilà
qu'aujourd'hui on met tout en oeuvre
pour transformer les grandes métropoles
en forteresse c'est à dire en empêchant
les banlieusardes des gens sensiblement
moins riches d'accéder aux grands
bassins d'emplois en 15 ans dans cette
tâche là beaucoup plus difficile c'est
pour ça en dit long sur les intentions
d'une certaine gauche qui a renoncé
quelques parts au progrès pour toute une
population afin de la gt des
considérations tribales
finalement cette politique anti voiture
n'est que la déclinaison locale d'un
tribalisme généralisée que l'on retrouve
à toutes les échelles
aujourd'hui alors tribalisme qui se
décline à l'échelle nationale ça existe
et nationaliste c'est le protectionnisme
tribalisme communautaire c'est ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui avec les tensions
ethniques dans la société et bien la
politique anti boîtes chaude hidalgo
c'est la déclinaison municipal d'un
tribalisme d'un repli alors même que
paris comme toutes les collectivités
humaines ne peut pas vivre en autarcie
totale vivre sans les plus commerciaux
qui la fait vivre les paris sonne pas
conscientes de leur interdépendance avec
la banque mais l'horaire de la france et
c'est dommage et c'est dommage pour
ensuite pour le fait que les
considérations et les motivations
avancées son combat fallacieuse parce
que on parle beaucoup d'écologie débris
mais en train il faut bien comprendre
que dans l'histoire de l'humanité la
meilleure
de là conditions environnementales de
l'humanité n'a jamais été corrélés au
sabotage de la mobilité c'est le progrès
technique qui a fait que l'eire
aujourd'hui est plus propre qui ne
l'était hier
c'est l'innovation dans live dans le
traitement des fumées ses innovations
dans les pots d'échappement propre
aujourd'hui l'air plus rock
aujourd'hui tu es la proportion de décès
liés à la pollution dans le monde recule
partout sont des chiffres qui sont
inondées les tables du rwanda où aller
sur google vous assure que la formation
est très accessible
donc voilà on dit aux gens je sais qu'à
clermont cher fergane pardon je vous
coupe la parole que
la qualité de l'air en ile de france ne
cesse de s'améliorer
les statistiques d'airparif sur internet
en témoigne même si personne ne le croit
parce que anne hidalgo passe son temps à
nous dire que on va tous mourir
deux axes fixiez si on ne met pas la
[ __ ] douce sur la circulation
automobile alors nos internautes je vais
revenir quand même et c'est dû à la
pollution de l'air n'a jamais été aussi
élevé non c'est faux monsieur techno
vous regardez les deux buts où se place
pas du tout avec nous tu sais les sept
rapports tout à fait officielle qui
émane de l'organisation de la santé les
paroles est aujourd'hui à 8,8 millions
le nombre de pertes de morts prématurés
dus à l'émission de particules à la
pollution de l'air je ne souhaite pas
monsieur 16 parcs droite niveau mondial
donc c'est pas du tout une fake news je
sais ce sont des rapports à fait
officielle les deux grands fléaux
monsieur environnementaux que sont la
pollution de l'air intérieur et
extérieur diminue partout parce que dans
les pays du tiers monde on a accès à
l'électricité dont on n'est plus obligé
de se chopper et de faire la cuisine
avec en brûlant des combustibles solides
à l'intérieur et en quoi la salle r on a
la parole mais ça serait utile parce que
j'aimerais quand même alors je vais bien
sûr vous la donner la parole cheikh
maxime des gayets juste un mot pour vous
dire parce que je veux c'est un sujet
qui m'intéresse beaucoup moi aussi qu'
il y à un débat méthodologique sur ce
concept de mort prématurée
c'est à dire que effectivement il ya des
chiffres qui sont assez inquiétants j
smadja les cités à l'instant
d'autres spécialistes considèrent que la
façon de mesurer n'est pas aussi
précises et aussi convaincante que par
exemple est mort par accident de voiture
ou là vous mourrez où vous ne vous ne
mourrez pas je vous donne la vie de nos
internautes
d'abord leur vote sur twitter
rêvez-vous d'un pari sans voiture comme
abidal go c'est la question que nous
avons posée et vous êtes 65% à nous
répondre non voici l'avis du droitiste
paris salle avec de gros soucis de
sécurité en plus anne hidalgo supprime
la voiture brace qui nous regardent d'un
jeu de mot avec hidalgo à paris tout
part à vélo et puis nicole le périph et
ont emprunté à 80% par les banlieusards
de quel droit anne hidalgo peut-elle
réduire de plus en plus l'accès aux
voitures
évidemment on va revenir sur ce sujet de
la banlieue puisqu'on a la chance
d'avoir le directeur de cabinet d'un
maire de banlieue
encore un mot celui de lorenzo qui nous
dit est un livreur je peux vous dire
qu'en l'espace de cinq ans je peux
livrer 30 % de produits en moins étant
donné l'augmentation de la circulation
et puis voici un dernière arguments il
est développé par ci cambre sur le site
du figaro sur lefigaro.fr
voilà la question qu'il se pose comment
faire avec des enfants et des vieux pour
l'interrogation sur le porte bagages
d'un vélo et la firme le commerce va
mourir
maxime des gayets la parole est à la
défense si vous voulez ça va être
compliqué d'avoir une défense avec des
arguments d'arrière-garde tels qu'ils
ont été déployés jusqu'à maintenant
objectivement non mais ce que disent et
organes diaries me franchement mais
stupéfié parce que il ya une confusion
sur deux sujets donc je vais essayer
d'être pédagogique
le premier c est ce que la place de la
voiture dans la ville aujourd'hui doit
être diminuée évidemment et évidemment
pour des raisons d'ailleurs du débat
précédent puisque si on veut que les
débits soit plus vivable si on veut
remettre les citoyens et les habitants
au coeur des villes c'est bien normal de
réduire la place de la voiture en
développant des circulations plus douce
et donc c'était 2-2 ce point de vue là
j'ai envie de dire
tout le monde le fait et on a bien
raison de le faire parce que c'est
évidemment positif est en tout cas si on
veut reconquérir d'une certaine manière
les villes relais végétalisée si on veut
les rendre plus agréable à vivre
eh bien il faut évidemment réduire la
place de la voiture c'est du bon sens si
j'allais dire que d'agir ainsi
le deuxième sujet que vous posez et de
dire mais on interdit les voitures on
empêche l'accès à paris là c'est une
vraie question
mais pour le coup je vous permettrait de
considérer que vous et répondait de
manière assez confuse
pourquoi d'abord c'est quoi aujourd'hui
la réalité d'abord évidemment pourrait
accéder en voiture et autrement à paris
demain comme aujourd'hui il s'agit pas
d'interdire les voitures comme j'entends
c'est réduire la place de la voiture
petit à petit 2 le deuxième sujet qui
est posé c'est de évidemment d'être en
capacité d'offrir des capacités de
mobilité de flux à l'ensemble des
franciliens et vous voyez bien
aujourd'hui que on développe
parallèlement à la réduction de la place
de la voiture l'augmentation des
transports en commun de l'offre de
transport en commun
on est en train de développer on porte
ça à la ville d'ailleurs comment on a
obtenu que la région s'ils engagent
d'amener en place d'un réseau deux
adjoints hervé de vélo pour permettre à
chacun de pouvoir se dépasser de la
meilleure façon qui soit et enfin et
c'est là où vous permettrez de peut-être
trouvé un argument qui à ses frais les
termes de l'accusation c'est quoi
aujourd'hui
la vitesse moyenne à paris pour les
voitures c'est 15 km heure 15 km et et
qu'on parle aujourd'hui de gens et quand
on parle du périphérique
vous savez ce pc que mettre le
périphérique
aujourd'hui à 50 km 1 ça veut dire que
vous ferez le périphérique hommes
combien de temps
en 42 minutes aujourd'hui c'est pas 50
km à la vitesse moyenne du périphérique
que subissent d'ailleurs les franciliens
ces 32 km et on a vu ces dernières
années qu'en réduisant la place de la
voiture surtout en offrant d'autres
types de mobilité
eh bien on ne pouvait permettre à ce qui
est des usages différents et on pouvait
permettre à ceux qui ont vraiment besoin
de se déplacer en voiture de le faire
dans de meilleures conditions ce serait
plus facile et plus rapide
donc permettez moi de penser que seul le
débat tel qu'il est posé et quand même
assez incroyable
si vous voulez pouvoir utiliser votre
voiture correctement et ben vous devez
au contraire continuer à soutenir la
politique mise en oeuvre par anne
hidalgo pas bien compris parce qu'en
fait elle est faite pour la voiture
cette politique d'un idéal go si si on
vous entend gilles smadja sur ce point
précis
est ce que on va rendre encore plus
difficile l'accès de
des habitants de banlieue à paris avec
ces mesures moi je pense que c'est une
ces mesures elles vont dans le bon sens
c'est absolument il faut absolument
réduire la place de la voiture dans les
villes il faut absolument réduire les
émissions de co2 de particules
il faut réduire tous les facteurs de
pollution qui ont de graves conséquences
en matière de santé publique
en revanche en revanche il faut que
c'est pts que toute décision qui
concerne le périphérique soit une
décision partagée
seule la ville de paris ne peut pas à
elle seule décider de ce qui a des
conséquences pour des millions de
personnes qui vivent en dehors de paris
et donc il faut absolument que ce soient
des décisions partagées
il y à un espace politique pour cela
d'ailleurs qui a été créé pour ça qu'ils
s'appellent la métropole du grand paris
et franchement s'il ya au moins un sujet
sur lequel la métropole du grand paris
devrait débattre et prendre des
décisions c'est la gestion du
périphérique
je pense que ça serait tout à fait
logique d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas que
c'est la métropole du grand paris qui
est à l'origine d'une mesure dont vous
n'avez pas souvent parler et c'est
dommage qu'ils s'appellent d'azf de la
zone à faible émission c'est à dire le
fait que à partir de bientôt dans
quelques mois
eh bien on ne pourra plus rouler à paris
et en proche banlieue avec des voitures
qui ne qui auront des critères trop
anciens est trop polluants donc ça veut
dire que et ça c'est pas seulement la
maire de paris qui l'a décidé ce sont
plus de soixante dix maires eux
l'ensemble de la banlieue parisienne
donc ce n'est pas la conscience qu'il
faut réduire la place de la voiture
n'est pas
quelque chose qui ait vu unilatéralement
par la maire de paris tous les maires
aujourd'hui la grande majorité des
maires de banlieue en conscience de ce
problème mais il faut il faut agir
ensemble pour pas paris décide pour les
banlieues il ya quand même 100 mille
personnes aujourd'hui qui vivent à moins
de 100 mètres du périphérique est donc
effectivement je rejoins ce qui vient
d'être dit sur l'enjeu c'est la police
qui est posée par ça et donc quand on
dit qu'on ne peut pas toucher aux
périphériques
allez le dire aussi aux 108 personnes
qui vivent à côté qui sont généralement
d'ailleurs les plus défavorisés de la
région ile de france
c'est alexandre devait clore votre point
de vue sur ce sujet moi je rejoins
fergane nous aimait bien son idée de
l'autre alors ne vous entend plus mais
ça va sûrement revenir pendant que la
liaison pendant qu'on est en train de
rétablir la liaison avec alexandre je
vous donne
anne hidalgo une partie de ses électeurs
vous me voyez plus non mais en 12 ans
alexandre et c'est l'essentiel
je disais qu anne hidalgo une partie de
ses électeurs
défendant la poste le vivre ensemble
mais je prends je n'aime pas tellement
vivre vivre ensemble notamment avec la
banlieue et les classes populaires
elle ne risque pas de murs autour de
paris mais c'est un peu un peu tout
comme il ya un mur invisible qui fait
que ça devient très compliqué
effectivement de se loger à paris mais
aussi de circuler et que effectivement
paris devient une ville de riches une
île où il ya plus d'enfants plus de
famille et moi je prouve que c'est voilà
que c'est assez désastreux du reste on a
vu avec deux épisodes que ce soit les
gilet jaune ou avec le co vide qui
atténue une france des invisibles qui
bien souvent faisait tourner le pays qui
était relié d'une certaine manière aux
grandes métropoles mais qui a des
besoins de la voiture pour pour produire
et faire srwt a encore une fois tourner
le pays
l'économie s'est pas seulement des gens
connectés qui bossent
en télétravail donc je crois qu'il faut
pas à cette france là et qui a une
grande politique territoriale à mettre
en place et qu'on peut pas exclure comme
ça du jour au lendemain la voiture
mobilité faut faire un effort sur les
transports en commun parce qu'il ya des
lignes qui ne sont tout simplement pas
praticable ou trois formations de de ce
tueur de surpopulation de voix là où
c'est pas agréable tout simplement de
dire que votre information
guillaume c'est très important bah
seconde c'est que aujourd'hui dans le
département des hauts-de-seine qui est
pourtant dirigé à une écrasante majorité
par la droite
à une écrasante majorité par la droite
est bien dans le département des
hauts-de-seine
le président l air de ce département
vient de décider de mettre en place des
pistes de vélo dans plusieurs dizaines
de kilomètres de voies départementales
et voyez donc c'est pas c'est pas
seulement la mère du pac outre les six
ans
voilà il se sera le mot de la fin je
vous interromps chers amis pour laisser
le dernier mot aux internautes rennaise
qui nous se posent cette question et si
c'était un problème de transport en
commun insuffisant on l'a juste esquissé
loft qui est d'accord avec alexandre ii
vecchio la politique anti voiture est un
désir des bobos parisiens de rester
entre eux affirme-t-il il ya cette
question d'expats aussi et on fait
comment la nuit sans voiture quand il
n'y a pas de métro
donc le bus pour l'interrogation c'est
vrai qu'il ya des bus la nuit même s'ils
sont peu nombreux
et puis je vous livre en conclusion ce
témoignage de chardons bleus qui nous
dit j'aime bien ces parisiens qui n'ont
pas de voiture et qui vous sollicite
pour aller les chercher où les
accompagner à la gare merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre merci à vous chers
internautes pour toutes vos réactions
vos points de vue et puis on se retrouve
bien sûr demain à la même heure et au
même endroit
bonsoir à tous